and if I want to get to the next level
it's gonna require a level of focus and
intentionality that I haven't demanded
of myself before so I'm gonna give you
the three ways to do it I'm gonna give
you the step by step on how to adjust
your habits become getting rich is not
an act it is a habit rise and shine it's
an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
tweak your habits over to you Mel
Robbins also if you want to hear what
Mel Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
confidence check out my 2:54 of
confidence series I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see your brain helps you you have no
clue what you want I'm gonna say that's
total bull every day for the next 254
days I will send you a 30-second two
5-minute video for free every morning to
help you build unstoppable confidence
the link is in the description
[Music]
I realized that I need to have a level
of focus and a level of intentionality
that I have not yet Ulta vated in my
life that there still that I do that I
put in the way that was fine when I was
operating and achieving at this level
but now I want to go to this level and
so what are those things getting up
earlier being a complete Hawk about how
I'm spending my time and attention that
in the mornings when I'm with my family
literally being hyper focused on just
them so that I'm present with them and
then confession I'll literally work for
like 25 minutes and then the ad D kicks
in and then I'll find myself folding
laundry for 20 minutes because I allow
myself to get distracted
see that's the thing about habits and
the levels of success that you get to
that when you recognize that jumping to
the next level that you want to get to
is nothing more than just tweaking your
habits a little bit that it's really
that simple you will start to be able to
have quantum leaps and I'm realizing
that I have amazing habits but they have
gotten me to here and if I want to get
to the next level it's gonna require a
level of focus and intentionality that I
haven't demanded of myself before no
drinking during the week being super
super focused on the stuff that's really
important probably hiring somebody
full-time to be a full-time assistant to
help me stay organized and focused in
terms of scheduling and weeding through
all the incoming requests I think it's
just about that about this sort of like
maniacal focus on things that are
important like now is the time and
what's cool is you can make it happen
any time in your life like if there's
some jump that you want to make look I'm
an extraordinarily productive person
I've accomplished a tremendous amount in
the last three years but what it's gonna
take for me to get to the next level and
not destroy the people around me with my
stress and be an amazing leader and be
an amazing mother and be an awesome wife
and actually be an incredible
businesswoman is a level of focus that I
have never required of myself what got
you here will not take you there your
habits your mindset your belief system
the friends the people around you that's
everything in your life that got you to
where you are right now will not help
you make the
quantumly forward to the person that you
want to become as an entrepreneur to
continue want to do this big mission
it's a constant shedding of skins for
someone like Mel Robbins to go from
where she was at to where she's at now
it's a constant shedding of skins for
someone like Oprah Winfrey to go from
this absolute poverty of warring potato
bags to schools address to becoming the
billionaire it's a constant shedding of
skins shutting your mindset shutting
your belief systems jetting some of the
people around you because all of that
got you to a certain level but they
won't help you jump to the next one of
my favorite examples from my own story
is I grew up in a really humble family
my parents are super humble my father
especially is a very humble man had
success but it's just humble and ain't
always the point where you know not
taking credit and it's everybody else is
great the super humble main and that's
it's a amazing trait that he had the way
that I adopted it is I would see myself
as being not good enough that yes I was
humbled but I wasn't good enough to be
like oh I can't go off and do that big
thing I'm just I'm just this little
person and the more I surrounded myself
with the content on my own channel I
found that my confidence grew that my
belief in myself grew because I'm around
believes so much my belief group if you
are around confident people you'll
become more confident if you are if you
want to learn Japanese go to Japan
you're around Japanese people you will
learn Japanese everything is
transferable you soak up your
environment so if you change your
environment you tweak it you make it
work for you you will adopt a new
mindset a new belief system a more
empowering one for you if you select
your environment correctly so I'm
driving with my dad we're going to pick
up a new car for him and I just signed a
new deal with sage sage is an accounting
software company multi-billion dollar
company you know 13 14 15 thousand
employees and every month the CEO and I
get together on a call a Google hangout
and we answer your questions and it's
been a ton of fun a huge blast over the
past couple years but when I first
signed that deal I remember riding in
the car with my dad he was asking me
what what gives you the confidence to
feel like you're on the same level as as
the CEO of this giant company and he
wasn't asking in a in a negative tone he
wasn't
saying like who are you to think you can
do that you suck more in a admiration
like wow this is so amazing I'm so happy
for you how did how do you think you can
do this and for me it wasn't even a huge
deal I love the idea Stephen Kelly loves
entrepreneurs it's a fantastic
collaboration but I wasn't super nervous
or starstruck because I feel like I've
hanging around every day with Oprah
Winfrey and Steve Jobs and Elon Musk's
and these people because of what I make
what every content that I create is in
my environment I consume it and that
shifted over time my belief system my
mindset my values the way that I think
about things has shift has grown
stronger has made me a better version of
me but I can never pinpoint like one
video that did it there's not one moment
that made that shift but to my father's
point he was correct because if I looked
at the oven from five years before I
probably would have been able to make
that deal I probably would have
sabotaged it somehow because I felt like
I wasn't worthy enough of doing that
thing I'd be too scared and too nervous
and as a result I'd find an excuse a
reason why I couldn't do it but the real
reason was just fear but by doing the
routine that I do by watching the videos
that I watch that I create for you guys
it shifted my strength it shifted my
belief my self-confidence and I was able
to do it and now I'm able to do bigger
things and so I think it's really
important to keep that in mind that the
habits the the friends the people around
you what you're doing right now got you
to where you're going and you'll
continue on this slow path hopefully you
know hopefully it's not just straight or
declining but if you want to make that
quantum leap forward you want to take a
jump you want to go up the next step on
the staircase you're gonna have to make
a shift somewhere in your environment in
your routine in your habits in your
mindset in your belief system so I'm
gonna give you three ways to do it I'm
gonna give you the step by step on how
to adjust your habits number one figure
out what is the habit that you want to
just what is the mindset what is the
belief system what is the thing that you
feel is keeping you where you are and
preventing you from growing so mal was
about focus what is it about you is it
focus is it self confidence is it belief
is that judgment losing a fear of
judging front of the people like what is
the thing what is the habit of the
belief system that needs to tweak for
you that unless you tweak that you won't
go to the next step write that down like
big letters number one
period and then the mindset or habit
ship that has to happen for you to take
that next step forward
number two is surround yourself with a
daily resource so whatever that habit is
that you want to go and accomplish if
framel its focus then you need to have
something in your environment that
triggers focus on a daily basis it's why
I created the 254 series the first one
is 254 confidence which I talked about
at the beginning every day for the next
254 days I will send you a video for
free that helps to build your confidence
if you are around people who are
confident every single day you will
naturally become more confident again
it's not a big ship that happens in one
video but the cumulative effect if
you're doing it every single day you're
not being distracted you're not watching
something off you're not playing with
the dog you're just watching a video for
30 seconds to 5 minutes every single day
you will become more confident and my
goal is to be able to apply that to lots
of other areas so Mel wants to focus on
focus I want to create a 2:54 on focus
so that if you want to say more focus
this is it this is the daily trigger
this is the daily reset every single day
2:54 is because it takes 18 to 254 days
for a new habit to stick the average is
66 days so most people quit before it's
cemented itself because the average is
66 days but it can take a minimum of 18
up to 254 days so I call it 254 because
I'm there with you every single step of
the day even if even if you're the worst
like you were the worst you are you're
the worst case scenario it takes you 254
days that have it to stick I will be
with you every single step of the day
now I've only done it around confidence
again I want to spread out into other
areas and also go into niche categories
like artists and writers and athletes go
down that path but until then figure it
out for yourself
find a daily resource that helps you
build that new habit so who are the
people who are focused or hangul handles
really well or whatever the habit is
that you're trying to fix and the
surround yourself with that a little bit
on a daily basis doesn't mean have to
watch five hours of video every day
right just a little bit 30 seconds one
minute two minutes five minutes nothing
short just to trigger so every day you
got that reset where you're triggering
that new mindset that new belief system
that new ability and then step three is
publicly share your journey I'm a big
believer in public accountability that
when you are on
Jurnee if you share it you're much more
likely to stick to it
and when I go on and I share something
on my Instagram stories or my YouTube
videos I tell what I'm up to then I feel
accountable to do it one because I've
made a public commitment so other people
are holding me accountable I said I want
to do is I want to make sure I do it but
also it's inspiring for other people if
you are trying like MELAS to stay more
focused all right if you're trying to
build more confidence and talking about
how you're trying to build more
confidence and talking about the
struggles that you're having and the
difficult is in the pain how you don't
always get it every day but you're on
your journey to do it it doesn't matter
if you are ultimately winning yet just
the fact that you are willing to try is
an inspiration just the fact that you're
willing to try becomes a shield for
other people to say look what he or she
is doing I want to do it too
you have to worry about having the best
video production but you're just getting
on the phone loading up Instagram
stories and three to five times a day
share in your journey what you did today
what you're learning how you're growing
how you feel compared to where you were
yesterday or last week or last month is
an inspiration to others and it keeps
you more committed to the journey and so
I think ultimately as entrepreneurs we
want to make the world a better place I
think if you have the ability then you
have the responsibility if you can than
you must and sharing the document in the
journey when you can help somebody else
up it keeps you more committed
Alcoholics Anonymous one of the twelve
steps is being a sponsor to other people
part of what helps you stick to not
going back to alcohol is helping
somebody else out stay sober if you
didn't help the person out stay sober
underneath you then you are much less
likely to stay sober yourself as well
and so for me in the morning as an
example part of my morning routine the
one that gets me the most excited most
ready for my day to have on fire starts
in the morning is I need to share a
message it's not enough for me to just a
consume content I need to share
something and in the sharing and knowing
that it's being broadcast to others and
it's reaching some people that makes me
feel good that allows me to start my day
off on the right foot so those are the
three steps to change your habits to
helping you shed your skin and help when
you reach that next level I have a very
special bonus clip for you that I think
you're really going to enjoy but before
that question of the day I want to know
what is the habit that you need to
change what does that have it that will
help you jump to
next step on the staircase leave it down
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus
[Music]
we are what we repeatedly do human
beings we are creatures of habits you
notice that you kind of do the same
thing the same routine over over and
again and again and again see become
getting rich is not an act it is a habit
so it is staying poor it's also not an
act it's not something just happens to
you it is a habit so let me teach you
the three best habits of rich people the
very first habit of rich people and that
is they count their money poor people
don't count their money they get a
paycheck they deposit a paycheck they
spend the money they have no idea what
the expenses are you have no idea how
the money flows you notice poor people
they say oh be they have a job and wait
till maybe once a year when they found
out they would text return is the Texas
that I own is how much of the pay they
look at the numbers do you even look at
the numbers it's just okay all right
that's what how much I need to pay
without tax return and death yeah look
at it maybe maybe once a year rich
people we don't do that we look at our
numbers record we are financially
literate I'm not a numbers person don't
get me wrong okay I'm a concept guy okay
I'm a big-picture thinker I'm a
visionary but I am very very careful and
I'm very aware how my money is flowing
habit number two is they pay themselves
first now you've heard of this before
oh yeah I know then I've heard of this
this before you got to pay yourself do
you know actually what that means paying
yourself doesn't mean by yourself it
doesn't mean taking that vacation it
doesn't mean that you know you would you
know you go blow money on entertainment
oh yeah I'm paying money myself
no that's paying everybody else when
you're buying a car you're paying the
automotive motive company when you're
buying a house you are paying the bank
when you are traveling you're paying the
the traveling agency you're paying the
hotels
you're paying the the the flight company
airplane company paying yourself meaning
that you put your money aside and you
invest your money now I'm not talking
about being frugal you know if you know
anything about me you know my work I'm
not talking about being fool girl in
being cheap I'm talking about thinking
as percentage of the income and putting
that aside pay yourself first and save
it and then you invest it that's what I
mean by paying yourself and a lot of
people if you read the book that richest
man in Babylon it talks about that you
should save ten percent of your money
and pay yourself ten percent number
three and that is rich people are
constantly improving their earning
ability because you might be thinking
Darren okay I want to pay myself first
but I'm not making enough money I'm only
making a few dollars in a month i
couldíve
I couldn't even afford to pay my bills
how am I gonna pay myself first first of
all you gotta have the habit of paying
yourself first if you're not paying
yourself first even a tiny small
percentage when you're making 30 40 50
60 $100,000 a year I guarantee you when
you're making a million two million
dollars a year you're not paying
yourself it is a habit that I'm talking
about and in order to do that in order
to be able to every single year to be
able to pay yourself more and more and
more and put into investments you need
to improve your earning ability you need
to find ways how you can add value to
the marketplace how to add more value to
the marketplace so every single year
your income is going up every year if
you've been you've been working in Aus
in the real world and you have your own
business and your income kind of stays
flat for the last two three five years
then shame on you it means you're not
learning it means you're not thinking it
means you're not growing every single
year your income you have to strive to
improve that your earning ability and
the rich people we're always constantly
looking for ways to improve our earning
ability but also looking for ways to end
leverage to apply leverage into what we
do raise your standard Apple at the core
is core value is that
and not one drop of myself work depends
on your that's something sue me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details